the gyro can experience when you were on
Stern - it came up so it was almost kind
of encouraged because well again Howard
gets a bad rap sometimes I mean
encouraged by him again again Howard
tried to help me a lot and he was he was
good to me I just he didn't like again
when you're on a junkies life eventually
you don't know what to do you don't know
what to do if you don't live that life
like Howard and I a lot of our rapport
on the air work because he was the most
disciplined human being ever and I was
the most undisciplined it was like The
Odd Couple so he from the first time I
went in there with Norm Macdonald I had
the story about getting arrested a man
thievery he just goes I said I love out
of control guys or fun yeah so when I
got on the show it's four and a half
hours of filling every day where part of
my life
so I would talk about going to Vegas and
gambling and you know but I I'm on the
you know I'm on the air
you're the cameras always on you on that
show so I'm on the air committing
felonies like like I got I'm coconut
bookies dealers office I there was a
guard there after Heath Ledger died as a
joke I said I had the same dealer as
Heath Ledger as a joke
and it was a joke the DEA shows up at
Stern with it with the with the
windbreakers on says he is gotta talk to
already pulled me out throwing a
commercial I'm like I'm at work bro and
they said and I I was joking around I
told him I was I was joking around and
one of the guards were [ __ ] gangster
the DEA and how just look the reason he
gave me to look great you Allah gave me
[Laughter]
[Applause]